There is a patient
He ate sesame oil chicken
And some supplements after
Found out while sleeping
Oops, what happened to my arm?
Red ones came out piece by piece
Then it itches and itches
It's so itchy it's tingling
Oh, so this
It's urticaria.
Wow, what should I do?
I'll teach you.
OO first
Then come again
Press 1 acupoint
The itching is relieved immediately
Hu Naiwen starts his lecture
I'm your old friend, Dr. Hu.
I want to share this episode with you
urticaria
eczema
Atopic dermatitis
herpes zoster outbreak
How to quickly relieve itching
Acute phase
Avoid these trigger foods
Urticaria attacks in the middle of the night
2 acupoints to relieve itching
What if one day
you accidentally eat something bad
like that patient?
What to do if urticaria breaks out
in the middle of the night
How to relieve itching of hives
Don't catch it yet
Teach you this trick
Press the acupoints first
Apply a cold towel
felt more than half comfortable immediately.
There are two acupuncture points to relieve itching
Qū chí (transliteration)
Xuè hǎi (transliteration)
Where is the Qū chí (transliteration) acupoint located?
Qū chí (transliteration) is when you bend your elbows
so that your palms face you.
On the horizontal line
at the elbow
Right here
It is called Qū chí (transliteration)acupoint
When you press it
you'll feel a soreness and a little pain.
Hey, it feels really sore when pressed.
It helps you clear away heat and detoxify
Helps you relieve the itching feeling
Another acupuncture point is called
Xuè hǎi (transliteration) acupoint
It's on the upper edge of the inner knee.
About three finger spans up
You press with your thumb like this
It covers
that knee
Then the point pointed by the thumb
It's called the Xuè hǎi (transliteration) acupoint
You use this thumb
press here, presshere
You put these two acupoints
One is Qū chí (transliteration)acupointand the other is Xuè hǎi (transliteration) acupoint
You are right here
Come and press
Relieves itchy skin
It's very, very good
And these two acupoints
Each press should last about 5 to 10 seconds
Repeat for two minutes
You can press it when you feel itchy
After pressing the acupoints
Apply a wet towel or ice for 5 minutes
Relying on vasoconstriction and cooling sensation
The itching sensation will be greatly reduced by half
Acute attack period
Remember one thing
Don't use too hot water for bathing
According to statistics, Taiwan has 5 million people
had urticaria before
In other words
on average one out of every five people wins the bid.
You said it's not too much?
Yes, someone close to me has also been diagnosed recently.
There are two types of urticaria
The first is acute urticaria
Healing in just a few weeks
Most are caused by food allergies
The second type is called chronic urticaria
It happens repeatedly.
More than 6 weeks
The causes are complicated.
And there are twice as many female patients
as male patients
If you find
haven't seen any improvement in more than 6 weeks.
Don't hang on there.
Let the doctor find out the cause
as soon as possible
I recommend you see a Chinese medicine practitioner
The effect is very good
Seasonal change is the peak of urticaria
7 Foods to Avoid When You Have Acute Urticaria
Urticaria is most common in spring and autumn
Appears during the change of seasons
It will be combined with cold, heat and dampness
Come and trouble you together
When the temperature fluctuates
Humidity fluctuates
The body's defense ability is reduced
It's easy to suddenly get a rash
Itchy and can't stop scratching
If you eat a lot in winter
Ginger Duck
Sesame Oil Chicken
barbecue
strong taste
Damp heat in the body continues to rise
Urticaria can be easily induced
Healthy people
Want to prevent urticaria attacks
9 types of food that should not be eaten in excess
Lamb Beef Duck Goose
chili, pepper, curry, and coffee
There are also snacks with a lot of additives
You can eat guava normally.
Kiwi fruit is rich in
Fresh fruits and vegetables rich in vitamin C
Helps fight inflammation and relieve itching
Don't eat too much in winter
BBQ, fried and spicy food
If you are now
Acute stage of urticaria
Don't eat
seafood
shrimp
Crab
clams
There are also
Walnut
Almonds and other nuts
Instant noodles and spicy foods
Can easily induce urticaria
Avoid certain foods during the acute phase
What can eat during the acute phase?
Three key points
Prototype Food
fresh food
Minimally processed foods
Fans leave messages to share with me
He used to work late at night
rarely eat fruits and vegetables, only eat meat
Eating seafood and lack of sleep
Acute urticaria occurs
It itches so much that he keeps scratching
Also scratched the skin
It's really painful
Since switching to eating prototype food
Gluten-free
No refined sugars
Urticaria no longer recurs
Looks
If we want to take good care of our mouths
we can't eat anything
That's right
Adjust your diet and daily routine
Urticaria will soon go away from you
Aloe vera and it
are magical in treating eczema
Eczema is a general term for dermatitis
Like atopic dermatitis
Seborrheic dermatitis
Dyshidrotic eczema
These can cause
inflammation, redness, and scaling of the skin.
Tissue fluid exudate
It can be called eczema
What to do if eczema is too itchy
Use aloe vera to help you relieve itching immediately
Did you know
There was a poet in the Tang Dynasty named liú yǔ xī(transliteration)
He recorded in his chuán xìn fāng(transliteration)
He said he had eczema when he was young
No matter how treat it, it won't work
Later met a medicine seller
The medicine seller taught him
1 liǎng (transliteration) of aloe vera plus 0.5 liǎng (transliteration) of roasted licorice root
Grind into powder
Wash the eczema area with warm water first
Then apply the medicinal powder
didn't expect the condition to improve so quickly.
Even its effect
It's very
magical
People who grow aloe at home
You can use it to apply a
very nice
Do you have aloe vera at home?
Apply it like this
You'll know it works.
Aloe vera is the savior for itchy skin
There are four effects
Relieves itching, reduces redness and swelling, k
ills bacteria and repairs damaged skin
What’s even better is that aloe vera
can also help improve eczema, sores, and hemorrhoids.
That market
Is there any aloe vera gel available?
If the ingredients are very natural
You can try it
But I still recommend
using natural aloe vera.
Now let me tell you
How does Western medicine treat eczema?
Many people encounter eczema or skin problems
The first reaction is to take anti-inflammatory medicine
Allergy medicine or steroids
These medicines are designed to relieve itching.
Very good effect in a short time
But I tell you
Long-term use is not good
Your skin will become thinner
Even increase the risk of
osteoporosis
and hypertension
The price is high
There is a great trick to eliminate eczema
More important than anything else
Just don't catch it.
Just tickle it
You keep scratching until your skin breaks.
I told you it was infected.
The skin will only get worse
Getting worse
Give you a new idea
Skin inflammation is not a bad thing
It's the body's way of resisting external stimuli.
Eczema is a sign of organ dysfunction
To truly cure the root cause
Traditional Chinese medicine emphasizes
regulating the internal organs from the root
Improve your disease immunity
Rather than just suppressing inflammation
A soup that relieves the itching caused by atopic dermatitis
Any skin disease can be cured
Traditional Chinese Medicine for Skin Diseases
First look at the constitution and cause of disease
Symptoms
It belongs to fēng huǒ shī zào hán (transliteration)
Which one
Just divide virtual and real
Is it acute or chronic?
Eczema is the most common skin disease
Atopic dermatitis
Mostly hot
Hot weather or eating too much
spicy food, etc.
It is easy to occur
This kind of person also has trouble falling asleep at night.
Unbearable itching
There are two ways to improve
First, drink mung bean soup
Mung beans can clear away heat and detoxify
Reduces heat and relieves itching
But don't drink it iced.
Otherwise, the ice cream
will trap the heat inside your body.
On the contrary, it is easy to affect the circulation of qi and blood,
which is not conducive to the dehumidification function of the spleen and stomach.
Don't eat for now
Fish, shrimp, crab, bamboo shoots, taro
and spicy foods
or hot tonics
For example, sesame oil chicken, ginseng, and pepper
Ginger, onion, garlic, etc.
These will increase shī rè(transliteration)
and inflammation in the body
So eat more
mung beans, bitter melon, winter melon, chrysanthemum, coix seed, and poria cocos.
These heat-clearing ingredients
No. 2
You can use barley soup
for bathing
It can relieve itching regardless of body constitution
Records in the Golden Mirror of Medical Ancestors
Boil 1 liter of barley into soup
Fumigation before washing
What does 'Xūn' (transliteration) mean?
That's it
When the steam
is burning
fumigate the itchy area.
First fumigate
and wait until the soup gradually cools down
before washing
If you have this problem
Why not try it tomorrow?
This method is not only effective
for atopic dermatitis
It is also effective for psoriasis
urticaria and eczema
Shingles are more likely to occur in autumn and winter
Sesame oil + it
Immediate relief for pain and itching
Taiwanese people get shingles
Also known as the pí shé (transliteration)
Also called fēi shé (transliteration)
pí shé (transliteration) or fēi shé (transliteration)
With chickenpox
It's actually the same virus
The probability is as high as one in three
Change of seasons or over 50 years old
These two types of people whose immunity
is already relatively low are most likely to be induced
Acute episode of herpes zoster
Not only it itches
And it will burn like fire
Like a needle prick
It hurts so much
You can do this
Buy realgar powder at a Chinese medicine store
Add a little sesame oil to mix
Mix it
into a paste
Then apply it on the affected area
It will scab over in about a day or two.
Can help relieve
the pain and itching
But be careful
If symptoms are severe
You must see a doctor immediately
Especially the older ones
or those with weakened immune systems
Get early treatment
During the acute phase
you should also avoid irritating foods
such as duck, goose, beef, and pig skin.
These are not edible.
Is shingles more likely to flare up in autumn and winter?
Yes. Why?
Did you know
Because the immune system is at this time
Especially prone to decline
It's because you use all your energy
to fight the cold.
So the chickenpox virus lurking
in the spinal nerves
Maybe at this time
It was triggered
Along the nerve fibers
At the nerve endings
Start to breed
At this time, blisters appear
Causes severe pain and itching
tell you a little knowledge
If your child had chickenpox
when he was young
Instead,
he will never have thispí shé (transliteration)disease again in his life.
Of course if he
It can still happen even without an outbreak
But if it happens
when are young
This pí shé (transliteration) will not happen again easily.
So if you have little kids at home,
There's still this opportunity.
Dear fans,
We have opened the membership channel
If you agree with Dr. Hu's promotion of Chinese medicine
The concept of taking care of your own health
Small monthly donations are welcome
Just the price of two cups of coffee
Or become a VIP sponsor
With you
We can go further
Thank you very much